SPEAKER 1: A large temple
engulfed by a fine white dust
cloud, colorfully dressed people
walking toward the entrance.
You may have
already guessed this
is a picture from Burning
Man, and you may have already
started to roll your eyes.
But no matter what your
ideas about the festival
are, once you see these pictures
of the art, the structures,
and the people,
you might actually
want to experience
it for yourself.
SCOTT LONDON: Hi, my
name is Scott London.
I'm a journalist and a
photographer from California.
This is a photo taken at Burning
Man, an annual gathering that
takes place every summer in the
Black Rock Desert of Nevada.
This is the Temple of
Transition, a massive art
installation at
Burning Man 2011.
At the time, the
temple was rumored
to be the largest wooden
temporary installation
in the world, of sprawling
dream-like structure made up
of five small temples
and a center tower rising
about 120 feet above
the desert floor.
SPEAKER 1: But don't let's
Scott's sincerity fool you.
He also once rolled his eyes
at the thought of Burning Man.
SCOTT LONDON: I had no interest
in going to the event when
I first heard about it.
I had seen images
of people doing
crazy things in the desert and
decided that it wasn't for me.
If I ever make a trip to
the Black Rock Desert,
I thought to myself,
it'll be to enjoy
the beauty and the
serenity of the place,
not to share it with tens of
thousands of other people.
But after my girlfriend had
gone with some friends of hers,
she came home insisting that we
go together the following year.
SPEAKER 1: Eventually,
Scott gave in
and traveled to the Nevada
desert with his girlfriend.
And he never really looked back.
He's returned to Burning Man
every year for the last twelve.
SCOTT LONDON: Burning Man
means different things
to different people.
Some think of it as a
week-long party in the desert.
Others see it as an
art festival where
installation artists
from around the world
come together to
exhibit their work.
Still others describe it as
a kind of social experiment,
where people go off
the grid for a week
and create a temporary
community where
many of the rules and
conventions of ordinary society
are thrown out.
Unlike a traditional
festival, where
you go to be
entertained in some way
and where there's a clear
boundary between the performer
and the spectator, Burning
Man is participant-driven.
Everybody contributes something
to the overall experience.
And I love that.
I find that it's endlessly
fascinating to see
what people come up with.
SPEAKER 1: And there
was only one way
Scott could think of to capture
the creativity of the festival.
SCOTT LONDON: I found
that it was simply
impossible to describe.
And I realized that my best
hope of conveying the experience
would be through pictures.
For me, what makes
Burning Man special
is that it's a kind of
laboratory for creativity.
Everybody is encouraged
to express themselves
in some capacity, through making
art, playing music, walking
on stilts, fire dancing,
or simply being beautiful.
SPEAKER 1: For more
"This Happened Here,"
check out this episode on the
world's largest treehouse.
SPEAKER 2: It's 97 feet
tall and is supported
by six different trees.
The treehouse was well known
to those who lived in the area,
and I'd been hearing
about it for some time.
SPEAKER 1: And don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.